police officer eric talley was one of 10
people killed in last week's supermarket
mass shooting
in boulder yesterday his friends and
family gathered to say
goodbye 500 law enforcement vehicles
from across the country
participated in a procession escorting
his hearse wow look at that
to the memorial service just outside of
boulder janet shamley and watched the
tributes
the cars stretched for some eight miles
a number of first responders on
horseback
and people gathered on the side of the
road in below freezing temperatures
as a community came together to say
goodbye to officer eric
talley i just feel it's so important to
let the family know that we're here and
we're supporting them and we care
at the church fellow officers saluted
the flag draped casket
and family photos of the 51 year old
husband and father of
seven were shared as his life
and heroism were honored your father was
kind
your father died a hero there is no
doubt
because of his bravery dozens of
innocent lives were saved tally was the
first officer to arrive
at the king superstore when a gunman
opened fire last week
nine others also died police say talley
was the last to be shot
in that rampage his sergeant recalled
talley's commitment
eric was the kind of guy who was so
vibrant and enthusiastic about life and
the job
he wanted to share with the world he was
the kind of person to give you the shirt
off his back
even if he had to borrow it from someone
else first eric
would give his all and give his all he
did
many now hoping officer talley's
sacrifice will be remembered
not by his death but by how he lived
eric talley's patrol car parked here
outside the boulder police department
now covered in flowers and tributes his
family asked
not to appear on camera during the
service but they did offer a poem that
his seven children
wrote for him and gave to him on
christmas in 2019
and it reads in part dad our unsung hero
you daily risk your life to guard and
care for the welfare of the needy
oh our praises could never be enough
they sound like pretty great kids tony
janet thank you pretty great kids but
pretty great dad pretty great dad pretty
great family and then eric talley's
father did an interview a couple of days
ago where he said
his son was always known for doing the
right thing and he died doing the right
thing
it's tough looking at the family photos
though of what was lost that day it
really is and he didn't have to be a
police officer he chose to do that
late in life their journey is just
beginning that family and i hope that i
wish them the best we all do